pour leur première conférence de presse
depuis un mois et demi les docteurs ou à
louer longtemps arrivent avec leurs
masques ils prennent leur temps pour
l'enlever question de s'assurer qu'on
l'a bien remarqué mais vite les gens à
être prudents et s'ils le souhaitent à
reprendre le port du masque dix jours
après l'avoir retirée dans les
transports en commun la santé publique
n'a pas l'intention de réimposer le
couvre visage nulle part mais l'objectif
ici cedr applique la mesure demeure
efficace surtout pour les personnes
vulnérables
moi si je me retrouvais dans un
événement des festivals que ce soit je
le porterai
bien peu de spectateurs semblé suivre
son exemple aux francofolies de montréal
et à québec où on termine le montage des
scènes du festival d'été des gens se
préoccupent de la montée des cas j'ai vu
ça avec les feux de la saint-jean qui va
plusieurs personnes
pas de masque ce mec est un peu avec une
santé précaire luis en face on veut
lancer un mouvement il a créé l'immuno
clip une épinglette sur son masque qui
avertit les autres quand tu vois le i
qui représente un petit bonhomme
immunosupprimées premières lettres du
mot immunosupprimées sa différence et en
moins adapté distance parce que ça peut
être toi ça peut être mon frère ça peut
être ton fils les nouveaux variants
demeure moins virulent mais plus
transmissible et comme l'influenza a
presque disparu des radars ceux qui ont
des symptômes ont probablement l'aco
vide en ce moment on a quand même tous
les éléments qui font penser à une vague
par contre est ce que cette vague sort
d'une ampleur comme la cinquième ou la
sixième c'est là que c'est loin d'être
évident un autre appel à la vaccination
est donc lancé particulièrement aux
malades chroniques aux immunodéprimées
et aux 60 ans et plus et comme
l'efficacité des vaccins diminue avec le
temps tous peuvent avoir exxon dose de
rappel dans la mesure où la précédente
dose date d'au moins trois mois la santé
publique répète donc le même message que
les dernières semaines au sujet de la
vaccination et elle ne ramène pas non
plus de restrictions sanitaires
mais elle agite le drapeau jaune en
espérant ne pas sortir le rouge ici
vérins et prince radio canada québec